I need a system-wide scan for a hard
drive serial number 18. sir serial
numbers have nine digits this has two a
one followed by an eight otherwise known
as eighteen find it
Silo episode 9 is titled the getaway
which prompts the question is it
possible to get away when you live
underground in a sealed environment like
The Silo to her credit Jules makes a
real go of it and whether or not it's
possible this idea of getting away does
create a great setup for this
penultimate episode tensions are high
for everyone involved and it feels like
something will have to give the pursuit
of Juliet keeps everything moving and
shakes details Loose as the episode is
forced to focus on one-to-one
conversations between characters with an
emphasis on the cost of Keeping a Secret
Finally in a situation where
everything's collapsing around Jewels
her pursuit of the truth about what
happened to George and why Allison and
Holston decided to go out to clean is
the only thing she has left unless she
can literally Escape The Silo she'll
eventually be caught and sent out it's
not a big surprise that Jules ended up
on the walkway of the floor below after
she went over the railing at the end of
the last episode she's battered but it
puts enough distance between them that
she's able to get out of there before
they can catch up with her there is some
suspicion that Billings might have let
her go because no one knows he has the
syndrome and lost his grip this puts him
in an interesting spot because he's
gained some respect for Juliet and has
started to recognize that there's
something going on at judicial that
doesn't add up when he goes home and
explains to his wife what happened she's
almost relieved and tries to talk him
into coming clean and leaving the
sheriff's department for good they get
into a fight and he tells her a story
about violently attacking another
teenager who realized they were both
hiding having the syndrome and that
points out just how far he'll go to
protect his secret his wife drops one of
the episodes most cutting lines after he
says he earned the job through his hard
work by simply responding but you lied
of course this makes you think about the
lies from I.T and judicial in the effort
to protect The Silo but it also does a
good job to highlight the stakes that
are inherent in situations like these
she's right about the fates of the last
two sheriffs and not wanting their
daughter to grow up without a father but
preserving this lie is so essential to
who he is he can't accept a different
path forward so he decides to go try to
catch Juliet so that he can make things
right after finishing up with the
initial search Sims goes to meet with
Bernard they start to discuss a plan to
find jewels and then Bernard gets
distracted by a beacon on his desk that
has started flashing it has a chain
connected to it and it's marked with the
number 18 which is a number we've seen
before it's the same number that was on
George's hard drive this thing is
mysterious to the point that I don't
know what to call it yet the flashing
light gives off signal or warning Vibes
but we don't get a full explanation for
what it is before for the end of the
episode one thing you do get a good
sense of though is that Bernard is
concerned when he sees it flashing and
before he sends Sims away he stresses I
hope you understand what we're facing
here and Sims gives a nod to acknowledge
that he does even if we don't the thing
about having the main character on the
run is that it means that the
investigation Works to check in with all
of the potential allies she's held on to
throughout this first season judicial
goes to visit a defiant Walker who
declares that she has nothing to hide
before letting them in Sims goes to
visit Pete Nichols giving him the news
in a somewhat unceremonious manner that
his daughter and only living family
member asked to go out he follows that
up with a direct threat invoking
overzealous Raiders and Pete reminds him
that he knows something about that
already Papa Nichols mentions a spot on
the railing of the level one balcony
that's been worn smooth from all the
jumpers gripping the rail before they
jump off adding thanks to your Raiders
Jules is all I have left the doctors
become someone we're invested in and so
it matters when he poses the question
would you help the people hunting your
child Sims immediately responds that he
would claiming that no one person is
more important than the 10 000 or the
thousands more to come this is exactly
what we expect from this character but
there's also been an emphasis on how
important his family is to him and we
get a hint of some internal conflict as
he stares into the nursery and thinks
about his next move as we catch up with
his wife and son on their way home we
find out that he sent some Raiders to
escort them and it's somewhat surprising
that she doesn't want to let them inside
you find out that she used to be a
Raider before she transferred to it and
you get the sense that she has some
feelings about that when she enters the
apartment she notices the camera has
been disabled so she secures her son in
his room and grabs a gun before
searching the apartment she notices the
hard drive on the bed and when she bends
over to look at it Jules comes up behind
her with a knife Sim's wife is a
character we know nothing about and the
way he's been presented hasn't really
sparked interest about his home life
either but Juliet's decision to hide in
a place they wouldn't think to check
makes for a memorable exchange as she
waits for the drive to load up sims's
wife asks about the comment she made
about nightmares and Jules tells her
about the Raiders coming into their home
and destroying it when she was a kid she
says that's judicial that's who you used
to work for and who your husband works
for now and the responses that her
husband works for the good of The Silo
to that Jules points out that it's weird
then that she doesn't believe in the
good of The Silo enough to let two
Raiders her husband sent into their
apartment and she comes back saying that
her husband's not in control of
everything that happens in The Silo and
he's certainly not responsible for
something that happened the jewels when
she was a child elsewhere Bernard
signals that he's completely stressed
out by pouring a drink and then pouring
it back into the bottle he looks at what
I guess I'll call the fob and sees that
it's not flashing anymore and then Sims
checks in to tell him about Lucas
getting the message from the Porter and
then going to jules's apartment speaking
of that after being sent Away by one of
his students from his Pac program when
he tried to get into the apartment
earlier Billings waits for them to leave
and sneaks back in he rigs the door and
then takes a closer look at the area
where the camera is placed behind the
mirror and he finds a piece of two-way
glass on the floor that they missed when
they were cleaning up he can't find
anything in the apartment but then he
remembers finding the Pez dispenser in
Doug trumbull's medicine cabinet and
goes looking at hers he realizes he can
pull it out of the wall and he finds the
Georgia travel guide behind it back in
his office Bernard call calls in Lucas
and breaks the ice by asking him about
sitting in the cafeteria looking at the
lights in the sky then he tells him he
knows exactly what happened to Jules
apartment only instead of calling it a
camera behind the mirror he says it was
an air quality meter and after he lays
it all out he asks Lucas what he did
after the meeting and when the answer is
that he did nothing he points out how
that's a problem the sheriff showed him
a red-level relic and he didn't alert
anyone to this situation he brings it
all back around by saying that as an
analytical person what does he think the
consequences should be for such an
inaction Lucas doesn't have an answer
for this so he threatens to send him to
the mines or maybe a cleaning and he
twists the knife a little bit by saying
that it was all because of a crush after
making mistakes clear he finally
browbeats the only possible piece of
information that Lucas has out of him
that the drive had the number 18 18 on
it and as soon as he hears that number
he rushes to the Janitor's Closet where
he tells the text to find it while
they're searching for the hard drive
Bernard says he's been very negligent in
appointing a shadow and that everyone
had presumed it would be Sims but he
tells him he found out about the escort
and now he's not sure if he's the right
person for the job he drives this home
by saying we're facing extinction and
you chose to protect your family before
The Silo before Sims can respond to this
they get interrupted when they find out
that the hard drive is in his apartment
Jules is able to get into the hard drive
she was able to figure out the password
from Allison's notes while she was
looking at it Sim's wife was starting to
pick the lock on her cuffs after
scrolling through the files Jules
notices one that's named start here and
when she clicks on it she sees a video
message from George which he starts by
saying this is a video at least that's
what they called it in the before times
why while she's distracted watching it
Sims wife does get the Cuffs off and
grabs a hammer she makes a very clear
decision not to attack her though
instead she tells her to stop and
explains that as soon as she connected
the hard drive they'd be able to find
her so she has a choice now she can run
and try to get away or she can keep
watching and by the time Sims and the
Raiders get there we see that she has in
fact left while this is all going on
Billings is in her apartment looking at
the book we eventually see him bawling
in jules's room as he finishes looking
at it and then he decides to put it in
the oven to destroy it before he does
that though he tears out a page which I
couldn't figure out exactly which one it
was but as the book starts to burn it
starts to set off the fire alarms from
there things really pick up we meet a
new character that passes a checkpoint
using his it badge we find out he's on
his way to Patrick Kennedy's apartment
where he meets Jules he's absolutely
reluctant to help until he recognizes
that it's George's hard drive he does
what hackers do he's able to bounce the
signal somewhere else and he's able to
get things going so that she can
continue watching George's message
through that she finds out that he did
have a plan to use her initially when he
went down to Mechanical but in the
process of that he did end up falling in
love with her he also says that he found
the door he was looking for that it's
huge maybe 15 feet tall that it's made
out of metal and that he couldn't get
through it but he adds maybe you can he
points out that she's probably wondering
what he did about the water and says it
turns out it was nothing to worry about
the important thing is that the door is
down there and that she has to find it
at the end he tells her he's making the
video in case he doesn't make it but
that people need to know why Allison
Becker went out to clean and he tells
her to look at the Jane Carmody cleaning
file which is the same one that they
found together when they first opened
the hard drive while that's going on we
see Sims and his wife talking where he
says he wishes he could have gotten
there sooner but she tells him that
she's glad he didn't because she let
Jules go this is complicated because he
gets pissed and she says she did it
because she knew he was on his way with
a group of Raiders with their fingers on
the trigger he assures her that he had
given them orders not to fire but she
comes back saying that she's been given
those orders and she knows what can
happen she ends the conversation saying
we have one goal one ambition we will
not lose sight of that which definitely
makes you wonder what that goal is while
it definitely involves him taking over
for Bernard it doesn't really feel like
they're trying to do that in order to
maintain the status quo it does give the
impression that there's more to this
Sims character than we've been led to
believe and he does confess that sending
the escort might have messed up their
plans which makes her look worried and
she he asked exactly what he said and
when their son comes up we do see that
he is affected by what he saw when Jules
was in the apartment the episode comes
to a close after we hear George's
heartfelt sign off that makes Jules cry
it's a great emotional moment for the
character and Rebecca Ferguson does a
tremendous job of delivering that then
Jules looks at the Jane Carmody cleaning
file and shows it to the other two this
time we hear her voice and she says the
display in the cafeteria people have to
know they have to see and then Jules
says Allison's right the display is a
lie and it zooms into focus on that bird
pattern that we saw reflected in
Allison's glasses when she was watching
the file
so yeah this was a great way to set up
the finale just a ton of character
moments that they've been working
towards throughout the season paying off
here we're at another point where most
of my speculation of what might happen
is related to things I know happened in
the books that's to say that there are
quite a few different things that could
go in different directions things I
can't be sure about which makes it all a
lot more fun the end of the episode is
so emotional and so exciting that it
almost makes you forget that there's
literally nowhere for Jules to go once
she leaves Kennedy's apartment the
hacker can hide where the drive
currently is and George's Revelation
about finding the door seems like it
presents a possible way to escape but
there really shouldn't be any way that
she would be able to make it to the down
deep they showed us that there's a
travel ban with checkpoints it's been
established that there's a Sheriff
Station down there and we saw that
judicial has a presence there when they
went to visit Walker and so she can't
just smash the the cameras out on her
way down the stairs still based on what
we've seen it feels fairly certain that
one of two things will happen she will
be caught and then she'll be sent out to
clean or she'll make it back down there
and go for the door and face her fear of
water I guess seeing the Jane Carmody
cleaning video might have the same
effect that it had on Allison and she
might not be afraid of going out but
considering that the hacker and Patrick
have both seen it too there's also a
possibility that they could try to get
that information out to everyone else
and then that would change things I
think the flashing keychain or whatever
we're calling that thing with the 18 on
it is the big WTF moment in this episode
but I have a pretty good idea of what's
going on there the things that I keep
thinking about are one what's going on
with Sims and his wife when I watch this
episode the second time all of their
scenes and the decisions they make
jumped out at me there's really no
analog for this in the book so when I
say I'm wondering if there's more to be
revealed about this character I'm really
wondering what's going on there the
other thing is Billings he left home
ready to double down on keeping a secret
and showing everybody he was the good
guy by bringing Jules in in pursuit of
that he saw the travel guide which had
an effect on him but what does it mean
that he destroyed it I really have no
idea where this character goes next and
I kind of laughed to myself whenever he
saw the pact on the desk and immediately
put it in the drawer this is the second
episode in a row that Adam Bernstein
directed and since the other episodes
were shot in blocks I assume that means
he'll be the director of the finale I
feel like that's a good sign this last
run of episodes has been really strong
and one thing that jumped out at me
again in this episode is how cool the
sets are the apartments all look unique
and they look lived in but also
claustrophobic in a way that you'd never
notice if you grew up in one of them
Rebecca Ferguson and Tim Robbins are
both a joy to watch they're both earning
their paychecks and as I've mentioned
chinaza Uche is killing it as Billings
but then even some of the minor
characters like his wife and sims's wife
have really made the most out of their
limited screen time which really adds to
the overall quality I guess as we near
the end what stands out the most is the
way everything is fitting together as a
book reader I can get distracted by what
I think should happen what I anticipate
seeing and then I'm left wondering why
they made different changes and at the
end of this episode it feels like they
knew what they wanted to do and are
pulling it off I can't wait to see how
they wrap things up and I think that's a
great place to leave things please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
thank you